you and Jason would be the most fun
parents ever how will you put your foot
down one day oh we will learn eventually
we'll learn but for now we can be fun
olivia wilde and jason sudeikis are
having fun with their almost two year
old son Otis but olivia is also giving
back to other kids the star was
recognized for her work would save the
children at varieties third annual unite
for Humanity event on thursday Save the
Children is responding to a very real
need in this in the world today I mean I
think the statistic is six million
children die every year from entirely
preventable causes and half of those are
newborns so when you have a stat like
that you realize this is a crisis and it
involves coordinating lots of different
humanitarian partners under one purpose
which is to help children whether
they're in conflict zones or whether
it's from famine or droughts than I
wanted to be helpful in some way and it
turns out the actress's work with the
organization has very much impacted her
life is a mom how is it influenced your
your parenting style in your
relationship with your son well I'm just
everyday more grateful and realizing how
I've completely won the life lottery and
it's just so clear to me at every stage
of his growth and my own growth is a
mother so it just makes me realize how
lucky I am and that because of that luck
I have a responsibility to help other
mothers